wow that's deep money fighting like a
film about to enjoy it to explore learn
be challenging yourself push your limits
being kind and helping helping your your
fellow runners and helping each other oh
my family marry the love of your life to
have children and to be happy just to be
happy and remember to smile being
present in the moment and not carry away
with your fear it's like an worry taking
advantage of the opportunities that I
given to you and you know just make any
best of them I think that's what you
know the spirit of the marathon is all
about it's all about testing yourself
which is a great great celebration and a
great opportunity to be here to be alive
and to be able to run 26.2 miles and not
die